kommunikation
das lexikon sagt dazu austausch oder
übertragung von informationen
aber wollen wir alle nicht einfach nur
verstanden werden richtig verstanden
früher am funk beim amt und heute noch
am telefon
gelingt das nicht hilft nur eins die
buch stabil tafel von a bis z von anton
bis zacharias war das schon immer so
andere zeiten andere worte denn für
nordpol war das schon immer so wenn ich
meinen nachnamen buchstabieren sage ich
wilhelm anton ludwig berta richard
ullrich nordpol nordpol
wieso halten sie das für problematisch
die nazis haben alle deutsche breischen
nahmen damals entfernen lassen und
beispielsweise wäre ihre beiden letzten
buchstaben der wären nicht noch cool
gewesen sondern nathan und noch ist
nicht einmal ein name sondern war in der
mythologie der nazis der aus modena ja
herkommen
1934 nathan verschwindet aus dem
alphabet die nationalsozialistische
oberpostdirektion will keine jüdischen
namen mehr hören
david wird zu dora aus jakob wird j
nur ein paar namen oder geht es nicht
darum mehr also sprache verändert sich
immer ob es um antisemitismus und
rassismus oder sexismus geht generell
und menschenverachtung und die frage ist
doch einfach sind wir teil dieser
entwicklung nehmen wir daran anteil
freiwillig oder aber wir uns hin und
sagen nein so wie es war so muss es
bleiben und ich habe keine lust mehr und
ich sag weiter zigeunerschnitzel und ich
sagt weiter lehrer und ich sage weiter
nordpol kann man machen ist halt nicht
unbedingt sehr sympathisch ein lesebuch
aus alter zeit gibt es gute oder böse
wörter antisemitismus in der sprache
das beschäftigt den journalisten ronen
steinke sprache transportiert manchmal
auch ganz zwischen den zeilen bestimmte
vorstellungen bestimmte bilder und wenn
man das ja sozusagen gar nicht merkt und
das einfach so so aufnimmt wie so kleine
dosen von asien die für sich genommen
nicht giftig sind aber über die jahre
sich anreichern
man kann sich natürlich da eine
ressentiments festigen
jedes wort hat seine eigene geschichte
und seine eigenen vorurteile beispiel
ist das wort mischpoke was oft verwendet
wird für so ein bisschen sinistre gruppe
irgendwie dubioser menschen zusammen das
kommt eigentlich aus dem jüdischen und
bedeutet eigentlich familie völlig
wertneutral also mit eigentlich mit
spucke ausgesprochenen jüdischen und in
der übernahme ins hochdeutsche als
lehnwort ist das so verwandelt worden
irgendwie negatives sondern irgendwie an
richtige fort und dieser
bedeutungswandel ist durch nichts
anderes zu erklären also dass man die
menschen die jede sprachen für irgendwie
dubios gehalten hat also das ist
natürlich antisemitismus der hat spuren
hinterlassen in unserer alltagssprache
seit der nazizeit fehlen in der
buchstabe tafel jüdische namen heute ist
für die buchstabiert tafel das deutsche
institut für normung din zuständig
denn in deutschland ist selbst das
diktieren normiert die buch stabil tafel
ist die din 5009 norden gibt es ja für
ganz ganz viele bereiche das geht vom
schnuller über die zahnbürste das
berühmte papierformat aber es geht auch
zur künstlichen intelligenz oder
industrie 4.0
also es gibt ganz ganz viele
anwendungsbereiche genommen und in
diesem fall ist es geht es um die din
5009 und die beschäftigt sich nicht
diktieren
und da spielt die buchstabiert habe
natürlich eine wichtige rolle dass man
sprache normieren kann halte ich für
eine legende oder für etwas naive
vorstellung
man kann vielleicht dominieren die
großen das papier zu sein hat in
deutschland habe
sprache ist nichts wo man irgendwie ein
regelwerk guckt man bevor man beginnt zu
sprechen da geht es um konventionen da
gibt es um gewohnheiten und da gibt es
höchstens darum impulse zu setzen
omas schreibheft von 1914
heute hat es buchstabieren vielleicht
weniger bedeutung als damals aber muss
das buchstabieren überhaupt normiert
sein und ist immer wichtig dass es aber
nicht um bürokratie gehört sondern um
jan transparenten prozess der da
stattfindet
nach gewissen regularien funktioniert
und zwar ist die leute denken wenn sie
enorm denken immer an regelungswut oder
so aber ich glaube das ist ganz ganz
wichtig ist dass es sie gibt und dass
das auch eine gewisse verantwortung
damit verbunden ist die man jetzt bei
der buga wird habe sid
eine experten kommission will bis zum
herbst eine neue buchstabiert tafel
vorlegen
ohne vornamen vermeintlich unpolitische
kann man einfach zurück in die
vergangenheit
bis dahin bitte lasst uns doch die
weimarer tabelle verwenden damit die
nazis hier nicht sozusagen in die
geschichte eingehen mit dem letzten
eigentlich wollen wir doch nur
kommunizieren einander eindeutige
zeichen geben wenn das mit der
buchstabiert tafel nicht klappt ob man
da am besten aufs gute alte winker
alphabet ausweichen
[Musik]